The date was April 3, 1919.
The location was the South Side Pavilion in
sunny Jacksonville, Florida.
The occasion was a much-hyped competition
of gastronomical strength between Ping Bodie,
the five foot eight and 190 pound New York
Yankee outfielder, versus the “world’s
greatest eater,” an ostrich named Percy.
They were to engage in a spaghetti-eating
contest to determine, once and for all, who
was Earth’s most prolific eater- man or
ostrich.
But before we recap how Bodie fared when he
went beak to beak with his feathered foe,
let’s see how we got here – to how and
why a baseball player named Ping Bodie faced
an ostrich in a spaghetti eating contest.
Ping Bodie was actually born Francito Sanguenitta
Pezzolo to an Italian-American immigrant family
in San Francisco on October 8, 1887.
There seems to be several different tales
on how Francito earned the name “Ping Bodie.”
Bodie himself said once that the name came
from a family friend who had been nicknamed
that, but didn’t like it and pawned it off
to little Francito.
Other stories claim that he received the nickname
because that was the sound the ball made as
it came off his mammoth 52 ounce bat, though
of course wood bats don’t make that noise,
so we’ll trust Francito on this one.
As for the surname “Bodie,” Ping’s brother,
Dave, explained in a February, 1912 letter
to the editor of the magazine Sporting Life
that “Ping” wanted to change his name
to something less ethnic because he felt was
going to be“ridiculed.”
After all, he was one of the first Italian-Americans
to reach the major leagues.
So, he chose Bodie – the name of a silver
mining town known for its salons and gunfights
that his father and uncle lived in for a time.
W.O.
McGeehan, the famous New York Herald Tribune
sports writer who also originally hailed from
San Francisco, claimed that Bodie built up
his strength at an early age by rolling heavy
rocks down Telegraph Hill to “keep their
territory free from invaders.”
Ping was a slugger from the start, beginning
his professional baseball career in the California
League in 1908 and then joining the legendary
San Francisco Seals (the DiMaggios played
for them as well, albeit 24 years later) in
1909.
He was called up by the Chicago White Sox
in 1911 when the owner, Charles Comiskey,
complained the Sox weren’t hitting; Bodie
went into his office and told him, “You
want some hitting, put me in the lineup.”
He did and Bodie hit, earning the nickname
“Fence-Buster.”
He soon clashed with with the White Sox manager
and was traded back to the Seals before finding
his way to the Philadelphia A’s, where he
once told the press that the A’s were so
bad that “I and the Liberty Bell are the
only attractions in Philadelphia.”
Always modest, he was finally traded to the
New York Yankees.
As you might guess from all this, Bodie was
naturally gregarious and loved being the center
of attention.
So, he was paired up with another larger than
life personality as a roommate – Babe Ruth.
The Babe was, already by then, well-known
for his tendency to hit the town.
So, when a reporter asked Ping what was it
like to room with the biggest star in the
game, his response was honest, “I room with
his suitcase.”
He’s also credited as being the inspiration
for the ballplayer in the book (and, eventually,
comic strip) You Know Me Al by Ring Lardner.
The book consisted of “letters” written
by a fictitious White Sox pitcher named Jack
Keefe to his friend.
In the letters, he reveals to Al all the shenanigans
that went with being a baseball player and
his obliviousness to the fact that he was
being taken advantage of by everyone around
him.
As for Percy, he was probably Jacksonville’s
most famous ostrich.
He had been touted by the Jacksonville Chamber
of Commerce as the “world’s greatest eater,”
likely as a way to promote the city’s zoo,
which had only opened five years prior in
1914.
In fact, Jacksonville was in the midst of
it’s run as the “Winter Film Capital of
the World.”
Before Los Angeles became the center of movie
production, silent movies were filmed either
in New York during the summer months or Jacksonville,
Florida in the winter.
It’s warm climate, exotic-looking locations,
rail access, and cheap labor encouraged over
thirty silent film studios to be established
in the small northeast Florida city during
that time.
Additionally, Jacksonville had been home to
spring training baseball since 1898 and the
residents loved having the ballplayers in
town.
So, when the co-owner of the Yankees, Colonel
T.L.
(Cap) Huston, heard that the city was touting
their long and slender ostrich as the best
eater in the world, he knew they would play
along when he offered up a challenger in the
form of Ping Bodie.
The match wasn’t widely advertised due to
the fear that it would arouse anger from animal
lovers, but by all accounts the local Jacksonville
hall was packed with spectators for the vent.
Bodie, given that he was the challenger, was
allowed to choose the food.
Percy raised no objection.
Bodie’s choice was spaghetti.
Members of Jacksonville’s Chamber of Commerce
who had wagered quite heavily on Percy did
not like this pick.
After the first three bowls, man and ostrich
were neck and neck.
It was said that Percy “gobbled his third
bowl of spaghetti with such gusto that he
accidentally swallowed (the manager’s) pocket
watch and chain while the manager was timing
him.”
By the fourth bowl, “Percy’s sides had
begun to swell visibly.”
At the sixth bowl, several female spectators
headed for the exit not wanting to see what
would happen to the poor bird.
By the eighth bowl, it was becoming clear
that Bodie was going to win the battle.
But, still, the bird kept going.
During the tenth bowl of spaghetti, a spectator
supposedly yelled “Do you want your bird
killed?”
Finally, as Percy ate his eleventh bowl of
pasta, he stopped eating, staggered off and
collapsed.
Bodie finished his bowl, emerging the victor,
supposedly stating “When the timekeeper
counted to ten, the ostrich keeled over, never
to rise again.”
The ostrich supposedly died.
Of course, whether that’s exactly what really
happened or that the victory was slightly
embellished by those covering the event for
effect is up for debate.
For instance, I’m *guessing* Percy didn’t
actually eat the manager’s watch.
And it seems odd that the ostrich would choose
to eat itself to death, rather than just stop
when it was full up.
But an ostrich staggering away and keeling
over does make for a better story than one
that simply stops eating.
For reference, ostriches typically eat about
8 pounds of food per day, processing it in
their three stomachs, including a gizzard
which seemingly would have little trouble
grinding up pasta.
Their gizzard can hold at any given time about
2-4 pounds, nearly half of which is generally
rocks and sand used for grinding the food.
They also aren’t super picky about what
they eat, consuming plants, seeds, roots,
insects, and small animals- pretty much whatever
plant or animal they can fit in their gullet,
they may try to eat if they feel so inclined.
Whether the ostrich actually died from the
event or not, reports all agree that Bodie
won (possibly more to do with lack of competitive
spirit in the ostrich than that Bodie’s
stomach could hold more than the ostrich’s.
But perhaps the massive amount of pasta really
didn’t agree with Percy’s digestive system
in some severe way.
Given ostriches eat grains just fine, this
seems unlikely though.
Any ostrich experts out there, please do ring
in on this one in the comments below).
Bodie made his last Major League Baseball
appearance with the New York Yankees in 1921.
He played for several more seasons for his
hometown Seals until retiring for good and
moving south, to Los Angeles.
He became a Hollywood electrician mostly on
the Universal Lot and even dabbled in acting
in a few films.
He was rumored to be friends with many members
of Hollywood royalty, including Carole Lombard
and Lon Chaney Jr.
To the day he died, in 1961, he still loved
talking about how he could “whale the old
apple and smack the old onion.”
Presumably, this means hitting a baseball.
But to others he will always be known as the
ball player who beat an ostrich in a spaghetti-eating
contest.